Hi, everyone. In this lesson, we're going to take a quick look at Landscape and some
of the tools and things you can use to get running and get ready to build your stuff
in Unreal for your game worlds. So let's get started. One of the first things that
a lot of people run into as in problem-wise when it comes to building your world and
using Landscape is how to interpret exactly how the section size, the scale, the section
per component and number of components as well as overall resolution all relate to each
other. Now you'll see this here, this little section I took from our documentation. I put
it in the slide so you can have a quick reference to be able to see how all these
work together. Now it's up to you how high of a resolution you want to go. Keep
in mind when you do choose a particular resolution, you need to actually consider
what it is you're doing and how you're approaching your world. You may not need a
highly deep, highly detailed polygon world. If you're setting something out, maybe
you're tossing it out to a mobile device and you just need something to convey the
idea of terrain in your character running on it. Then again, if you're working on
a higher level game, such as for PC or for console, you may want to go higher with
your resolution based on what you want to do for your world and how believable
those assets are going to be. This chart here shows you the relationship of how the landscape
component size as well as overall vertices size and quads all relate together, giving
you your total components. So keep these things in mind and the goals that you want
to tackle. Let's go and jump into Unreal and take a look at a few things and then
we'll get back into the slides and break down a few concepts. In Unreal, the level
I'm initially opening here is our in class speed building. We're going to go
back to that in just a bit, but as a reference point, we're going to leave
that open for now and we'll talk about some of the concepts we talked
about for building and we'll build a quick world later on in this section
of the course. Before we dive in too deep though into that, let's go and
take a look at the building of our terrain and maybe importing if you
wanted to say bring in a height map. Let me show you how to do that. So we go to
file, I'm going to go to new level. I'm going to choose a basic level. I'm
going to say create. In here I'm also going to delete the ground first
and then we're going to switch over to landscape mode. Now you can choose
whatever resolution you want. I'm going to leave this for now because what
we're going to do is bring in some height map data. Now if I hit create
it'll build my initial terrain and then we're going to get a node just below
saying height map. So I can right-click on this. As I do I can go to import from
export to file. In here I can choose what height map I want. Now for this
class I provided for you a free open source height map that you can use. So
you're more than welcome to use it or one that you already have. To be able to
access that I'm going to click on height map. You want to make sure you
click turn that on and then I'm going to click on the little dot interface
here to pull up the height map we want. I want to make sure it's
grayscale. That's going to be the most helpful and you can choose how
strong that's going to be by simply changing that in a desired DCC
Photoshop or whatever you might have it here on hand. So I'm going to click
on this. I'm going to say open. It's going to load it for us. From here I
can choose what kind of resolution I want. Overall this is looking great. You
also see there's a generic material which we can adjust and add later on if
need be. So I'm going to go ahead and click on import. It's going to now
import that height map, adjust it to what I have set in place and make it
so that our terrain is ready to go. From here we can go to sculpt if we
need to add more to it and you can see that it's grabbed the height map. Now
you could cheat also and get out of landscape if you ever needed to do
this. You can simply select your terrain if you wanted it more
dramatic and simply just use the scale option to maybe pull up some
of those resolution issues that you're like hey you know that just
isn't strong enough. We can do it through the widget which is a little
slow believe it or not or we can punch in those variables if we
needed to in our landscape editing tools because you'll notice when
you go to the details you won't necessarily have as much maybe
control as you want but hey we can still do it you'll just have to
fuddle with the numbers a bit more but you can also do it via the
managing of your editing of your terrain. So in this case we'll
say the z axis we're going to set this up to like 500 if we wanted
to. There it goes. And that looks a lot better. Now we have
the Lord of the Rings level environment. From here we can
load our materials and get things going. But believe it or
not loading a height map is actually that easy. Let's maybe
lower this down just a bit. We'll go to maybe half we'll go
to 350. Well, it's kind of half more 250 would be half.
Look at that. That's actually pretty nice. And it's all up to
you how you want to do it. And also what kind of resolution you
want to have. So we're going to get out of this for a
second. And we're going to go back into that environment
that we have laid out. And we're also going to go to the
slides really quick. And we're going to look at some
concepts. So let's go and do that first. So in the tools
that we have, once you've built your terrain, you can
choose sculpt. And in sculpt, you can left mouse click, you
can erase if you wanted to, that's a shift button plus the
left mouse click. There's smooth. If you want to smooth
things over, you can flatten. There's also a ramp, erosion,
hydro erosion, noise, general noise in your scene. And
again, this is important depending on your resolution.
It may look really bad if you have low resolution. So keep
that in mind. There's re topo for sections as needed. Maybe
you need one area to be a bit more dense and have a
stronger look, visibility, mirror, copy and select. Now
when it comes to visibility, if you wanted to like cave out a
secret hideout for per side of the mountain, and you
literally want it so you can climb inside of it, you can
actually do that. And that actually can maybe work in your
favor. Alright, so manage, let's go and take a look at
it real quick. And we're going to take a look at the
sculpting features with a built in material height map in
a scene already existing. From the scene that I have,
we're going to go ahead and open up the content folder
and go to our levels. And in our levels, we're going to go
to in class speed building. And we're not going to save,
you can save it if you want, I'm not going to. So in
this environment, let's go and take a look at what we
can do when it comes to sculpting. So I'm going to go
to my landscape mode. With my landscape move set, I'm
going to go ahead and do some sculpting in here. Now
you'll notice when I sculpt, the material is
reacting. This is actually pretty great. Now this is
literally just built into the material. If we wanted to
say go to paint, you will see the all the different
materials that are set up in here. And this is
basically a material that we made ahead of time. And
then when we build our terrain, this will be able to
be loaded. In this material, there is and let's go to
the folder for it. These default layer infos that get
created when you build out your material and you load
your shader texture network. So this is all I'm not
going to get into in this particular class. But we
do have a landscape class that goes into this in
more detail. The reason why I say that is because
it does dive into the weeds a bit. And what I'm
showing you here is the possibility of what your
shader can do. In our class, you will actually see
this shader that I'm working with underneath world
building for games. If you scroll down, you'll be
able to find it under materials and there you'll
see a landscape shader. So we're going to open up
this landscape shader for a second. And we're going
to take a look at the parent material for it. I'll
look at the instance material first and get an
idea of what's set up here. You'll notice there's
UV control, as well as a few other things such as
slope blend in detail. So again, we're not going
to get deep into this to show you how to craft
this because it this goes into the material
classes as well as a landscape. But I did want to
show you the height information which is loaded
in here. Now this is free on our marketplace. And
again, this particular one is the stylized Pro
Vin call that you'll see in our marketplace and
is a really awesome group of assets. If I pull
this down for a second and rotate the camera,
you'll see it has like a very ghibli looking set
environment. So in here, you'll see that they spent
a lot of work on this, you'll see that there are
layers for materials to work with, as well as a
landscape blend. Now this is very important to
have this landscape blend allows us to be able to
have these different aspects of textures in our
scene, you will see a set attribute in here,
which allows you to set and plug in what you need
and a world alignment blend in our scene, looking
at the slope, sharpness and slope bias. This
allows us to have that kind of that height
effect in our environment. You also see a
distance based tessellation and placement in
here. Now one thing I want to mention when
working with your environment, you want to make
sure especially if you're managing a lot of
overhead, like your trains pretty dense, like
maybe like that last map that we loaded, is
like, maybe you have a really detailed height
map, you can to help with that load, go in
here, select the terrain, and at any time in
your environment, you can choose to make that a
nanited terrain if you wanted to. Now this is
really up to you how you want to tackle it. And
if you want to go that route, to be able to do
so you simply select your terrain. Now you
would think normally you would say, Hey, I
want to grab this terrain, maybe in the
outliner, or over here, you won't see the
nanite pop up in these particular areas. But
you will find it when you do a search in the
objects details, and you will find enable
nanite. And you can build this right here. And
this can help with very complex terrain. So keep
that in mind. That is very helpful. And with
each new build of Unreal, it gets better, faster,
stronger. So in the next video, what we're going
to do is build a little bit of our world
by placing some of these objects in here, and
populating our environment, so that you can get a
better idea of some of the things you can do
when it comes to using some of the tools that
we've already covered so far. Thanks again.
Transcribed by https://otter.ai